okay I just want to say you know I saw
this story this morning it's from the
Daily Star a very reputable news outlet
and it tells it tells us that there's
there been these these sightings of UFOs
like snake-like
snake basically look like snakes in the
sky
I guess across the country and according
to someone who was interviewed by The
Daily Star the the US government is
investigating this and they're looking
into it to figure out if we're being
invaded by aliens they're very concerned
about it you know about the snake crafts
that are in the sky and I just want to
say that I especially after watching the
debates last night I am rooting so so
hard for an alien invasion at this point
not not foreign aliens we already got
that going on but like extra
extraterrestrials basically coming here
and enslaving mankind I am real I really
am rooting for that I think that would
be great if any aliens happen to be
listening to this broadcast right now I
plead with you I invite you please come
and enslave us all the whole humanity
thing honestly isn't working out very
well so if you want to just you know
that you're not going to encounter a lot
of resistance is all I'm saying now as
for the debate it was it was depressing
and disturbing on a number of levels but
I I I must admit it was also
entertaining as hell and that's that's
the main thing that matters right is
that we're entertained when we watch
these debates because so often the
entertainment factor just isn't there I
really enjoyed in fact there was one
point in the debate and this always
happens right you always have the goody
two-shoes who does this when you've got
people screaming at each other and the
audience is enjoying it we're eating our
popcorn loving every second of it and
someone always jumps in and says hey
guys guys guys let's this isn't what the
American people want to see
so last night it was I think it was but
a judge who who stepped in while during
the screaming match and said got me up
this is not why Americans tuned in to
debates and of course we're all thinking
no that's exactly why we tune into
debates this is exactly what we want to
say now if you're part of the Democrat
Party it's probably not good for you
it's pretty embarrassing but for the
rest of us I really like it yeah you had
Bernie shouting and until he lost his
voice you had Camela I think was
basically drunk
and erupting until after at
inappropriate times you had Andrew yang
tossing money into the crowd
Castro call it calling Biden and old
fart this this is basically what was
happening not literally what was
happening but this is this is basically
what was happening so we're gonna go
through and talk about the debate and
try to figure out just how just how
deeply into despair we should plunge at
the thought of these people controlling
the country at the thought that this is
a major political party in America and
this is what it has become we're gonna
talk about all that first though I want
to tell you about my my friends over at
light stream you know credit card bills
are something we all deal with every
month you get them multiple payments
multiple due dates it's hard to keep
track of all of it wouldn't it be easier
if you had all those what those those
payments in one if just one payment at a
lower rate what if you could do that
instead well you can with a credit card
consolidation loan from my friends at
light stream you get a rate as low as
five point nine five percent APR with
Auto pay that's lower than the average
credit card interest rate of over 19%
APR plus the rate is fixed so it will
never go up over the life of the loan so
you have that guarantee that peace of
mind and that's that's one of the main
things are getting out of this and then
that's what we all need I think in life
is peace of mind so just for my
listeners apply now to get a special
interest rate discount the only way to
get this discount is go to light stream
comm slash Walsh that's Li gh T STR e
a.m. dot-com slash Walsh subject of
credit approval rates include point five
percent auto pay discount terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice
visit light stream comm slash Walsh for
more information okay so the debate last
night a debate where Jorge Ramos helped
moderate Munich from from Univision he
helped to moderate the debate breaking
into Spanish at various points for no
apparent reason and here's the thing
Jorge Ramos is an American citizen he's
about 60 now he became a citizen when he
was 50 years old but he is and I was I
was reminded of this last night when I
when I was slightly critical on Twitter
of Jorge Ramos is in
element in the debate and my criticism
stems from the fact not from the fact
that he's that he's of Mexican descent
but the fact that he is staunchly
opposed to American sovereignty very
clearly and always has been
so I have to admit that it rubs me the
wrong way it does I mean I I was told
last night this makes me racist you're a
racist how dare you but it doesn't it
doesn't seem racist to me that I I it
does rub me the wrong way when people
come here and even if they move and
become citizens and then turn around and
lecture us about American sovereignty
and tell us why we shouldn't have
borders I don't like that you know I
that's I don't like him I admit and
that's that was Ramos --is function at
the debate was to sit there and lecture
the presidential candidates and to try
to prompt them to essentially disavow
American sovereignty which this is a
Democrat debate so they were more than
happy to do but that doesn't make it any
less of a repulsive spectacle in my view
I mean what do you think do you think
hold on a second I feel like Bernie at
the debate last night losing my voice do
you think Mexico for its debates do you
think it brings in American journalists
to lecture its candidates about its
border enforcement do you think they do
that well I I sort of doubt it
do you think any country in the world
has candidates who break into English
you know do you think any non English
country in the world has candidates who
break into English just to try to
impress everybody I really doubt it this
is all unique to our situation because
America is the only country in the world
that's supposed to feel ashamed of
enforcing its borders it's the only
country that isn't allowed to have
borders everyone else can have borders
Mexico has borders they enforce it as is
discussed sometimes Mexico has its own
southern border they enforce it but no
we're not allowed to do that and someone
from Mexico can come here even if they
move here and tell us no you can't have
borders shame on you and we're not elect
but you can't have any problem with that
y'all all you're allowed to do is just
sit silently and say okay sir yes sir
sorry sir yes sir if you try to speak up
and say what are you doing coming here
and tell us right if you do that racist
that's racist not right for my tweets
last night I've had all these people
saying are you gonna delete that tweet
and apologize when's the apology no I'm
not gonna delete an apology do you know
why because I don't care about your
opinion if you're offended I don't care
about your opinion and your outrage
means nothing to me so that's why I
don't apologize I'm just being I'm just
being Frank with you all right on a
lighter note for for for me the
highlight of the night was the fact that
Kamala Harris appeared to be drunk
that's the sense I got she appeared to
be drunk as a skunk I don't know but she
was the whole night she was like you're
drunk aunt at Thanksgiving laughing for
no reason well everyone just stands sits
there awkwardly you know you're in the
middle of a conversation the aunt pipes
and laughs everyone's like okay anyway
that's that's what it was the entire
night
III think maybe chugging Chardonnay
before the debate probably wasn't a
great idea
I guess they told her she needs to
loosen up she's got this whole image as
the she's got the cop image right as
someone who was and that's it doesn't do
well for Democrats so they told her
loosen up and I think she loosened up a
little bit too much and she tried to
turn the debate into a stand-up special
which I have to say out of recent
stand-up specials the way I would rank
them is probably bill burr number one
Dave Chappelle number two and then
Camilla Harris would be a distant three
now here's here's one of her jokes and I
want you to pay attention to the
moderators response to the joke here it
is watch this Donald Trump in office on
trade policy you know he reminds me of
that that guy in The Wizard of Oz you
know when you pull back the curtain it's
a really small dude
okay okay the clip cuts off so you don't
get to see Camila laughing hysterically
at her own joke for the next seven
minutes but I just I love the the okay
from the moderators it Trump is like
trumpets like The Wizard of Oz you know
the little small dude from Wizard of Oz
okay dude all right moving on
but here's I think this I think is drawn
is Comella drunkest moment and well you
tell me you watch this and you tell me
if this if this looks celebrate' to you
watch that today's former Vice President
Biden has said about executive orders
some really talented people are seeking
the nomination
they said I'm going to issue an
executive order Biden saying there's no
constitutional authority to issue that
executive order when they say I'm going
to eliminate assault weapons saying you
can't do it by executive order any more
than Trump can do things when he says he
can do it by executive order does the
vice president have a point there some
things you can many things you can't
let's let the senator answer oh I mean I
would just say hey Joe instead of saying
no we can't let's say yes we can instead
of saying instead of saying we can let's
say yes we can now actually the the
transition because what you didn't pick
up in that clip there what would the
clip cut off but the transition from
that joke to the point she really wanted
to make is what we need to focus on
because this is my favorite transition
I've ever seen in debate let's let's go
back to that clip and we're gonna play
it from when when the last one left off
watch
[Laughter]
you gotta come we can because I'll tell
you something the way that I think about
this is I've seen more autopsy
photographs than I care to tell you yes
we can but seriously I've seen so many
dead people
it's very traumatizing what was their
transition he was laughing hysterically
and she went from there to talking about
autopsy photos that was that was that
was good now what else happened a few
points let's see a few points I want to
go through here first the key okay the
candidates were given about 20 minutes
to talk about how much they hate racism
which wasn't even the biggest softball
of the night the biggest softball of the
night was the final half-hour when they
were all given the chance to tell
flattering stories about themselves
which we'll talk about a little bit
later but that was was seriously the
last it was a three-hour debate god help
us the last 30 minutes and I was
wondering why do you three hours how are
you gonna feel all the time well it's
because they wanted to leave the last
half-hour to give the candidates a
chance to say nice things about
themselves which they were more than
happy to do but for the racism thing but
a judge and O'Rourke you know being as
they were at a historically black
college and this is a Democrat debate
they really and they themselves of
course are white white dudes they really
turned the pandering mode up to turbo I
mean they really turned it on and but
there's a there's I think there's a
problem with the sort of pandering that
we see from on this particular issue
that we see from from from but a judge
and O'Rourke but we'll play the clip
first watch this I believe what's deepen
divisions in the country is the conduct
of this president and we have a chance
to change all of that
look systemic racism preceded this
president and even when we defeat him it
will be with us that's why we need a
systemic approach to dismantle it it's
it's not enough to just
take a racist policy replace it with a
neutral one and expect things will just
get better on their own farms compound
in the same way that a dollar saved
compound so does a dollar stolen and we
know that the generational theft of the
descendants of slaves is part of why
everything from housing to education to
health to employment basically puts us
in two different countries I have
proposed the most comprehensive vision
to tackle systemic racism in every one
of these areas marshaling as many
resources as went into the Marshall Plan
that rebuilt Europe but this time a
Douglass plan that we invest right here
at home to make sure that we're not only
dealing with things like the over
incarceration of black Americans but
also black solutions entrepreneurship
raising to 25% the target for the
federal government to do business with
minority-owned businesses investing in
HBCUs that are training and educating
the next generation of entrepreneurs we
can and must do that but that means
transcending this framework that pits us
against each other that pits a single
black mother of three against a
displaced auto worker because when I
come where I come from a lot of times
that displaced auto worker is a single
black mother of three we've got to say
that and bring people together okay
there's but a judge on on racism and but
I think again there's an issue with with
the way that a roar and mayor Pete try
to address this this this particular
issue and we'll talk about that in a
second but first a word from our friends
at VIN Shara watches as you can see I am
I'm wearing one of their they're great
looking watches right now and this is
what I want to tell you about this is
the best time for you to get one of
these watches as well because the
biggest their biggest sale of the year
is happening right now as we speak
here's the deal the more you shop the
more you save it works just like that
you could literally save hundreds of
dollars and this is the time to do it
right now we got the holidays that are
still still a little bit in the future
but why not start you buy it for
yourself you could buy gifts as well and
you only have this chance once a year
that's it everything on on the site is
on sale no exclusions no exceptions even
the all-new collection that they just
dropped that is also available on sale
products do sell out them so don't wait
at Doughboy don't wait to buy go now
because listen when it comes to watches
this is the best bang for your buck that
you're ever gonna have the chance to get
it really is as simple as that go to vin
cheerio watches dot-com it's VI NC er o
watches comm and start saving on amazing
watches that I'm telling you look a hell
of a lot more expensive than they
actually are than charile watches
dot-com alright here's the issue when
you've got but a digital Roark talking
about racism and so on systemic racism
you okay but you're two white dudes
running for president if you're really
concerned about systemic racism wouldn't
you drop out and throw your support
behind one of the candidates of color
that are running for president someone
like Camela or Booker or yang aren't you
because aren't you basically saying if
you think that there's systemic racism
in this country that it is ingrained in
our system then aren't you really saying
systemic racism is a huge problem and
the best person to fix it is me a white
man rather than a black man or black
woman or an asian man see that doesn't
make much much sense to me it's the same
problem that these pandering men have
like biden when they say oh yeah i'm
gonna pick a female vp because it's
about time that we had a female in the
white house just she shouldn't be at the
top though she should be right below me
not we shouldn't be at the top of the
food chain she should be one step below
it if you really feel that way but if
you really feel like it's so important
we have a woman in the White House that
I'm gonna make her my VP then then why
are you trying to take votes from female
candidates why not offer your services
as a women's VP okay rather than trying
to make it the other way around
that's what doesn't make any sense and
that's where the the I think the
pandering comes back to bite them in the
butt now health care they talked a lot
about health care I'm not gonna play any
clips but there was an interesting
blow-up over health care and we see this
every every time there's a Democrat
debate where you've got Warren and
Sanders insisting that everybody will
magically get free health care and
meanwhile you've got a few remaining not
yet full-blown socialists who at least
sort of under
and that you have to be able to pay for
things and so they're demanding that
Warren and and and Sanders explained how
they're gonna pay for this stuff
and they can't do it because there is no
way to pay for other than massively
raising taxes on everyone but Sanders
doesn't understand Sanders just yelling
and screaming and waving his arms around
like a maniac he doesn't he doesn't
understand anything
Warren too is completely completely out
of touch with reality and I thought that
Warren's
problem of being out of touch was
profoundly demonstrated by her opening
statement let's let's give a listen to
that
so I was born and raised in Oklahoma but
I'm sure glad to be in Texas tonight
my brother served in military bases here
in Texas that was their ticket to the
middle class me I got my big opportunity
about a half mile down the road from
here at the University of Houston back
when it cost $50 a semester for a price
that I could pay for on a part-time
waitressing job I got to finish my
four-year degree and I became a special
needs teacher and after law school my
first big job was back here in Houston
by then I had two little kids and when
childcare nearly brought me down my Aunt
Bea moved in and saved us all the paths
to America's middle class have gotten a
lot smaller and a lot narrower today
service members are preyed upon by
predatory lenders students are crushed
by debt and families cannot afford child
care I know what's broken I know how to
fix it and I'm gonna lead the fight to
get it done okay so you see the you see
this this theme that she keeps going
back to the opening statement
ticket to the middle class paths to the
middle class what she doesn't understand
probably because she's not middle class
she's upper class but she'll understand
is that is that being middle class is
not anybody's goal okay nobody gets a
job and says woohoo
my ticket to the middle class watch out
middle class here I come
I'm making $65,000 gee or my goals are
complete I am in the middle class smooth
sailing from here on out no people
that's not that's people aspire to more
than that okay most of us end up in the
middle class sort of by default that's
the thing all of this all of this is
sucking up that candidate's due to the
middle class and the middle class is so
great that's everyone in the middle
class you end up there by default it's
not you didn't want to be middle class
just that's where you are but the point
is everyone you know people aspire they
strive to move up that's what everyone
wants to do and there's not anyone
saying well let me get the middle class
let me get you know right there right in
the middle and I'm and I'm done I'm good
to go
it's not the way it works if you're poor
you'd rather be middle class than poor
but you'd also rather than rather be
well-off than middle class because
that's that's where people's aspirations
and dreams and goals go whether or not
their ever achieved this but what we
hear from Democrat politicians is is
what they're telling us is well we
should get to middle class you should be
satisfied with that
that's all now I as a Democrat
politician I can be rich right and have
three houses or whatever but but you you
should be satisfied and happy right
there we're gonna keep you right there
that to me is is a very concerning
attitude
speaking of concerning attitudes a whole
conversation about about guns and gun
violence bet O'Rourke went off on his
whole thing now he's going all in on gun
confiscation saying yeah we're gonna
take the guns we're gonna buy them back
which is to say we're going to steal
your guns and then compensate you with
whatever amount of money we decide just
which is like we talked about last week
it's really your own money so we're
gonna take money out of your pocket and
use it to buy your gun from you by force
and then you're supposed to be happy
with that so betos betos talking about
gun confiscation and there's a lot of
conversation about gun violence and gun
deaths and all these statistics flying
around about how many
gun deaths there are and the only thing
I want to say about that because I think
it bears repeating every time this
subject comes up when you hear all these
scary statistics about gun violence and
gun deaths specifically we should always
remember the gun death figure whatever
it is whatever they're gonna say it was
for twenty eighteen whatever it ends up
being twenty nineteen nearly two-thirds
of those gun deaths are suicides which
which is tragic and terrible and it what
we've really learned from that is that
there is a suicide epidemic in this
country there are a lot of people
committing suicide and that's something
we should be talking about the prop but
the reason we don't talk about that is
that it would be absurd obviously to
blame suicide on a gun even Democrats
aren't at the point yet where they would
do that because they realize that look
if somebody wants to kill themselves
there are many ways to do it and if they
don't have a gun there are dozens of
other ways and they could potentially
kill themselves so to blame it on the
gun just you can't do it it makes no
sense now it also makes no sense to
blame a mass shooting on a gun
necessarily but and they have no problem
doing that but the blame is suicide on
it is even more of a stretch which is
why they don't want to talk about that
instead they lump everything together
but two-thirds are suicides and you if
you're talking about the problem of
people killing other people with guns it
just you cannot lump suicides in with
that that's a different category of
thing tragic sad terrible something we
need to talk about and address but it
you cannot put it in the same category
as a mass shooting it's a completely
different phenomenon so we should always
remember that all right putting putting
the issues to the side for a moment I
want to say one other thing about the
debate I want to say something about Joe
Biden because Joe Biden I think had a
fairly disastrous performance I think
all of his performances of the debates
have been bad
I think his performance in general and
the campaign trail has been pretty bad
and and this is a guy that 15 years ago
if he was out on the campaign trail I
think he would
and formidable he did run for president
other times and and didn't succeed but I
think it was a formidable politician at
least he was a formidable politician for
most of his career because he's just he
was even though I didn't agree with and
I don't agree with his policies
relatively charming guy good on his good
at good on his feet all that kind of
stuff right a quick thinker well that
you know he's 77 years old now and he's
lost a lot of that began that's just
that's what happens to everybody if you
live long enough it's gonna happen to
you
where you get older and your mind
doesn't work as quick anymore and your
body starts shutting down that's it most
most men die before the age of 85 at 77
you are probably only a few years from
death that is the sad reality of being
puny mortals in living in the physical
world so I think it's been a sad
performance of overall and at the debate
last night it was it was especially bad
because he wasn't even making sense for
most of the time for instance watch
watch this clip right here nobody should
be in jail for a non-violent crime as
when we were in the White House would
release 36,000 people from the federal
prison system okay so he says nobody
should be in jail for violent crimes
so embezzlement child pornography
burglary those are all nonviolent crimes
so you're telling me those should be
legal well no obviously Biden doesn't
think that one would assume it's just
that he's not thinking clearly at all is
the problem now here he is here he is
making a point I'm not sure what the
point is he's trying to make but he does
seem confused about what decade we're
living in we bring social workers into
homes and pairs to help them deal with
how to raise their children it's not
that they'll want to help they don't
want they don't know quite what to do
play the radio make sure the television
the excuse me make sure you have the
record player on at night
the phone make sure the kids hear words
a kid coming from a very poor school I
have a very poor background
we'll hear four million words fewer
spoken by the time they get there no I'm
gonna go like the rest of them do yes
record players he's talking about record
players and this is what made it really
sting when Castro essentially accused
him of having dementia be enrolled they
wouldn't have to buy in that's a big
difference because Barack Obama's vision
was not to leave 10 million people
uncovered he wanted every single person
in this country covered my plan would do
that your plan would you do not have to
buy in they do not have to buy it you
just said that you just said that two
minutes ago you just said two minutes
ago that they would have to buy it you
said they would have to buy to buy in if
Spalla fire you are you forgetting what
you said of Maddox gonna be in for
[Applause]
what you said just two minutes ago I
mean I can't believe that you said two
minutes ago that they had to buy in and
now you're saying they don't have to buy
you're forgetting that anyone I mean
look grandmother who has no money she
will cursor automatically and radically
enrolls people regardless of whether
they choose to opt in or not if you lose
your job for instance his his health
care plan would not automatically enroll
you you would have to opt in my health
care plan would that's a big difference
I'm fulfilling in fulfilling the legacy
of Barack Obama and you're not I would
be surprised to him honestly honestly I
can't laugh at that that's that's brutal
and sad and and there's also a clip
floating around out there Biden
appearing to lose his dentures while
he's something weirds happening in his
mouth while he's talking I'm not gonna
play it
I just I don't get it with Biden you're
you're very old you're rich you've had a
successful life I mean most people will
never be vice-president most people will
never be senator so you've done that
you've achieved more than a lot of
people why not go home and enjoy your
remaining years go home with your family
and what's the why put yourself through
this he's not only having all these
gaffes on the campaign trail but at the
first debate he's accused of being
racist by Camilla Harris at this debate
he's accused he's essentially called
senile by Castro the guys being guys
being embarrassed up there and there's
there's no reasonable at least if he was
a younger man and you might say that
okay this is his first foray it's not
working out he could try again but
that's not gonna happen for Biden so why
not
go go just be retired go play golf take
up fishing you know how much I would
love if I could just go fish every day
and do nothing else that's what Joe
Biden could do at the age of 77 I it's
it's similar to how to how I felt about
Hillary Clinton although Hillary Clinton
is a is certainly a more repulsive human
being so it was a lot harder to feel
sorry for but but even with Hillary
Clinton's she's just falling apart
all these health problems she's an old
woman grasping desperately for this last
chance at power and you think why what
is it really worth it for all of this
even if you win you're gonna only be in
office probably for four years that's
all your body's gonna be able to take
and so you're and then you die soon
after you won't even be able to enjoy
the fact that you had all this power so
I don't get it
and here's one thing I want to say about
Biden in all seriousness at the end of
the debate as I mentioned they had this
softball segment that went on for way
too long where they asked everybody they
gave everyone a chance to tell a
flattering story about themselves and
they asked them the question was name a
time when you overcame adversity okay it
was an actual question asked at a at a
debate the kind of question that of
course will be asked of Democrats but
you'll never expect to see a question
like that asked of Republicans and
Bernie talked about when he ran for
mayor in in Vermont that was his
that was his overcoming adversity but a
judge talked about the fact that Mike
Pence's mean and everyone had pretty
pathetic examples of the adversity that
they overcame Cory Booker said his tires
were slashed one time well Biden talked
about losing his wife and child in a car
accident and then losing his son to
brain cancer years later and that's a
reminder that and there you have he was
the first person asked the question so
he gave his answer which is a real
answer I'm you want to talk about
adversity well there you go
everybody else's answers were
pathetically embarrassing by contrast
but it's a reminder that no matter how
you feel about buying him and I don't
like him but he has nonetheless gone
through the most painful thing any human
can possibly endure and every time I see
Biden in one of these debates I always
think about that he's gone through the
most painful thing anyone can go through
twice twice twice he's gone through it
and he managed to keep moving he managed
to at least pick himself up and and and
move on and
that counts for something I don't think
I could do it I don't think I could keep
living - god forbid I lose my wife and
child in a car accident I don't think
I'd want to be on this planet anymore
and certainly I wouldn't be able to
function at any level anymore in society
or the very minimum would take me years
to be able to do that but Biden has
marched on and I admire that on a human
level I I wouldn't be human if I
couldn't admire that I made this point
on Twitter and of course there were
sociopaths responding with thighs
nothing special what are you doing
giving Biden credit I mean come on let's
be human beings you go through something
like that that is as I said pretty much
the worst thing that could happen to a
bird not pretty much that is the worst
thing that can happen to a person to
lose a child and a spouse and then to
happen have it happen again and that's
all the more reason why I think the guy
should really just drop out and go home
and be with his family and enjoy his
remaining years he doesn't need this
there's no reason for it and I find it
sad all around I really do
all right Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com is the
email address this is from Maddon this
is from Adam says hey Matt I agree with
your take on the proposed ecig ban even
though I think vaping is a dumb thing to
do I also want to comment on what you
said concerning your own habits of cigar
smoking and drinking you said you don't
mind having a few years of your life
shaved off from these habits I totally
get where you're coming from
but you should also take quality of life
into consideration not just quantity I
work in health care on a daily basis I
see people with poor life quality caused
from poor choices especially those who
have long smoking histories they have
low energy frequently are short of
breath and often have to carry o to
tanks around everywhere they go it
doesn't look fun I think most of us have
room for improvement when it comes to
taking care of our bodies I know I do
the more we take care of ourselves the
more fulfilling our lives can be that's
my two cents in the matter keep up the
good work yeah well that's that's that's
certainly true and that's why I say that
the luxuries in life whether it's
alcohol or smoke an occasional cigar or
having chocolate cake whatever it is and
we all have things like that we enjoy I
think you got to do it in moderation of
course but the point is and if you don't
do it in moderation then as you say not
only are you gonna die sooner but your
life leading up to death is eventually
gonna become absolutely miserable
because of the choices you've made and
so that's no that's no that's no way to
have a help healthy happy and fulfilling
life I guess my point only is that you
could say well listen yeah you could
have have a chocolate cake have a piece
of cake every once in a while and it's
not gonna kill you and in in or have a
drink drink in moderation it's like okay
but you probably live longer if you
didn't do that stuff at all
so from a health perspective there
really is no health benefit to any of
that arguably maybe with alcohol in very
small doses maybe there is depending on
what study you listen to but probably
overall with all of those things whether
it's junk food or tobacco or alcohol
probably you'll live longer if you just
don't touch it at all and that's where I
say yeah maybe that's true but it also
brings you a little bit of joy a little
bit of happiness it helps you relax a
little bit and so to give all that up
your whole life just attack on a few
more years at the end I don't see how
that that trade is worth it
although yes the trade of I'm going to
do this in moderation so that I don't
die at the age of 50 that trade is
definitely worth it all right this is
from Jenny says dear Matt I wanted to
weigh in on the question of human
suffering you had mentioned that it's
hard to understand why God doesn't just
remove the suffering of innocent
children or suffering caused by natural
disaster I am a Christian I believe that
God does end our suffering for us either
through some sort of temporary relief
and eventually through our death it's
difficult to understand because we want
suffering to end immediately we may
suffer for a maximum of 80 to 100 years
if you have a very bad life and suffer
the entire time but since we have
immortal souls if we only suffer for 80
200 years at an absolute
maxximum what is 8200 years as a
percentage of eternity my point is that
those who are saved will have their
suffering removed immediately as
compared to the timeline of eternity a
lot of math heavy subjects but to
lighten it up I really enjoy your show
thanks for the work thanks for your work
well Jenny the point you raised and I
got several other emails making a
similar point as we were talking about
the the problem of suffering yet
yesterday on the show and and I said
that I do find it to be a profound
problem that is not easily answered and
I don't think can be debunked by
Christians I don't think there's an
answer we can give what we say well
that's problems done we came up with an
answer for the point you raise is a good
one and I don't disagree with it but I
think it doesn't quite answer the
problem of suffering it's part of an
answer it's part of the picture
certainly it's relevant obviously but it
isn't enough to diffuse the question
entirely in my view and I'll tell you
why first of all if you're meeting this
challenge from an atheist and generally
when someone raises the problem with
suffering in a in a in a debate context
that's gonna be someone who's an atheist
and they're giving one of the reasons
why they don't believe in God where they
say there's a lot of suffering in the
world 11 God wouldn't allow this that's
their argument
now I think there are various different
ways to address it even if it can't be
answered 100% you know completely but I
think in that context bringing up heaven
isn't gonna work because they don't
believe in heaven so in order for that
answer to work you first have to prove
the existence of heaven which in and of
itself is a tall order and so that's
that's the first thing to keep in mind
now second talking us to Christians I
think the answer the heaven answer still
leaves something to be desired because
for one thing for one thing not
everybody goes to heaven right so some
people will go on to eternal suffering
so what about the people who suffer
immeasurably in life and then go on to
suffer immeasurably in the afterlife
okay so I think bringing the afterlife
into this
really only makes the problem of
suffering more pronounced it really adds
to the problem of suffering where yeah
some people are going to heaven but not
everybody is and so what about the the
life of misery and suffering for people
who don't go it's just misery and
suffering the whole time forever and so
I think in a way you've you've added
another layer to the problem of
suffering and a more even difficult
layer I would say but even in the case
of someone so but let's put ok let's put
let's put that to the side and and let's
put to the side if you're having this
conversation with an atheist let's talk
for a minute about someone who suffers
greatly here but then does go on to
heaven
ok well certainly it will have been
worth it in the end I think we would all
agree but it still doesn't quite tell us
why God doesn't for example make
children impervious to can't to cancer
as he obviously could do being
all-powerful so think about it if your
child is in pain if your child is is
hurting and suffering are you gonna say
well it's okay that my child is in pain
today because we're going to an
amusement park tomorrow and they're
gonna have a lot of fun and forget all
about this now that's true of course he
will forget all about it that's the
thing about kids they get very wrapped
up in their emotions and they get very
wrapped up in the moment for good and
bad and they can act like they're
completely traumatized by something like
if you told them they can't have a snack
and they break down in tears and
meltdown thirty seconds later they're
over it and so let's say your kid is
really in pain we're really suffering in
his way over something are you going to
say that doesn't matter because I know
he'll be over it soon probably not you
still take his pain in a moment
seriously and if you could stop it I
imagine you would if you had the ability
to snap your fingers and make it go away
make the pain go away make the suffering
go away you would you probably wouldn't
say yeah let's just wait for tomorrow
he'll be fine by then I'll give you an
example my my son when he was about two
years
well maybe about a year and a half he he
fractured his leg on on the playground
and he was in a lot of pain as you can
imagine I've gone through that myself
recently and it's very painful and we
didn't realize at first what at apatow
because he wasn't he was he couldn't
tell us he was he wasn't old enough yet
to tell us and all we knew is he came
down a slide and he started crying and
we picked him up and he was crying them
my wife put him down for a second to try
to talk to him not knowing you heard his
leg and then he screams out in in pain
and starts limping and of course my wife
immediately scoops him up again it was a
temporary pain and he's over it by now
that was year and a half ago doesn't
even remember it I imagine but I still
think back to it sometimes and it still
kind of hurts my heart has a parent
thinking of that little guy in so much
pain and so unable to understand why he
was hurting or or when it would stop or
if it would stop that's the thing about
really little kids when they're very
sick or they're in pain or they're
scared or whatever that's what makes it
that's what really gets you as a parent
when you see your little children
suffering is that it's the confusion
that comes with it where they they don't
understand and you could try to talk to
them and say it's it's gonna be okay you
know it'll feel better they don't know
that and so in the moment for them they
think it's it's gonna be like this the
rest of their life they have no idea now
but with my son with his leg injury I
knew that he would get over I knew that
he would recover we could take him to
the doctor he wear the cast and
eventually you know he would be over and
and he wouldn't even remember it I knew
that but if I had a magic button I could
press that would have made that pain go
away I would have pressed it of course I
would I wouldn't have said I wouldn't
have said well why press the button
he'll be fine in a few weeks
of course I'd push it maybe what kind of
parent would I be if I if I didn't I
love my child I don't want him to suffer
and be in pain like that so I would take
it away if I could in fact if I could
push a button that would transfer the
pain in his leg to mile
I would have pushed it in a heartbeat
without question definitely so that's
why heaven doesn't quite answer the
problem with suffering because if even
if the pain and suffering is temporary
it's still real and see that's the other
problem that's why I'm sometimes
uncomfortable with people saying well
you know you go to heaven it has a way
yeah I know I know you didn't mean it
this way but it has it has a the effect
of being dismissive of earthly pain and
suffering and saying it doesn't really
matter it does matter it's real people
are going through it it's real and it
matters and why do children need to get
cancer just because there's heaven okay
you would never say of your own child
you know you're getting a treat tomorrow
therefore you must suffer immensely
today you would never say that about
your own kid so that's all to say that I
think the problem of suffering remains
you know I don't understand yeah I
understand that there's heaven I
understand that when you're in heaven
you're not thinking any more about about
those bad things but why do especially
little kids have to suffer in that way
just because there's heaven why can't
they just have a joy and happiness the
whole time I don't understand that now
I'm just being honest maybe I'm being a
little too honest but I don't understand
it I don't have the answer for that I
don't understand why God doesn't take
the pain away from those children right
now I wish you would I would but I'm not
God so I have to have faith that there's
a reason that that there's there is some
answer out there that I just don't
understand and and I don't think any of
us understand I don't think anyone on
earth understands it because because
I've never heard a person give an answer
that was completely sufficient which
tells me that none of us fully
understand it and I know it's see it's
really uncomfortable for us as
Christians
to admit when we don't understand
something and when we don't have an
answer for something we don't like to
admit it and we always want to had to
pretend that we have an answer at least
but I think we have to be ok with not
with not knowing and with not having the
answer I think we need to be ok with
that and I think it's ok to say I really
don't get this and it troubles me that's
okay too because that's real that's just
we're human beings we're trying to sort
through this and so when you see a child
suffering and you feel angry and you
feel you feel helpless and you say God
why don't you stop this I mean that's
that's just made that wish that's how we
should react that's how God wants us to
react that's just that's a reaction of
loves because we love those children and
we don't want to see them in pain and so
I think God can take that sort of
question even the anger we have and I
admit I have that anger sometimes at God
right say what you know when I see a
story about a four-year-old child the
one I talked about yesterday
four-year-old child hunched over a
toilet vomiting from his ki and
chemotherapy treatments and yeah you
know when I saw that I felt some anger
at God I felt like why don't you you
have the magic button why don't you
press it but I think that God can handle
that anger and I would even say that I
think maybe he wants us to have some
anger because where does the anger come
from it comes from love for the child
and a desire for joy for not just
ourselves but for others and that's
where it comes from it comes from a good
place and so I think I think far be it
for me to say but I think God is okay
with that all right
um so that got I got really heavy there
at the end we will we'll leave there but
I but I appreciate all the emails by the
way a lot of emails on this and all of
them very interesting and and so I you
know I think it's good that we're
talking about this and trying to work
through it have a great weekend
everybody I'm taking my son to his first
Ravens game on Sundays I'm pretty
excited about that
hope you have plans as well and I'll
talk to you on Monday Godspeed the Matt
Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 if you prefer
facts over feelings if you aren't
offended by the brutal truth if you can
still laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the Ben Shapiro show or you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more we'll
see you there
[Music]